in the perceived city of mariopol there
is no time to give the dead dignity
no respectful burial thrown instead into
a trench filling with bodies one after
another
in scenes we thought were consigned to
the middle of the last century but
happening now in a european city
the only thing i want is for this to be
finished i don't know who's guilty who's
right who started this
damn
have been killed in attacks ripping
apart the city's streets and homes
launched by one of the world's most
advanced militaries reducing living in
this seaside resort town to a struggle
to survive
in another resort this one in turkey
russia's foreign minister arrives
smiling for the highest level talks
since the invasion began but after just
an hour and a half they ended with
ukraine's foreign minister emerging
sounding frustrated my impression is
that russia is
not in a position at this point
to
establish a ceasefire
they seek
a surrender from ukraine
this is not what they are going to get
then the russians turn sergey lavrov is
a sharp operator who chooses his words
carefully but listen to this and wonder
what planet he's on
we're not planning to attack other
countries we did not attack ukraine you
said some time ago that russia had no
intention to invade ukraine i think
today you said that russia did not
invade ukraine when it clearly has
why should the ukrainians take you
seriously with all due respect why
should they believe a word you say and
the rest of the world
this is not about ukraine this is about
the aggression against anything russian
interests religion
language culture safety
and of course now the reaction of the
west to our actions very aggressive
reaction
russia has sent its foreign minister
here to talk peace but without a mandate
to discuss ceasefires or a new
humanitarian aid corridor claim the
ukrainians it's hard to see what these
talks have achieved apart from the fact
that they have happened and could happen
again
in versailles france european leaders
met to discuss ukraine but know the west
strategy of using sanctions to deter
russian aggression has so far failed
russia's advance is being blocked its
tanks here picked off one by one but the
more its military fails the more
barbaric it seems its tactics and the
more the people of ukraine suffer its
onslaught
dominic wagon sky news and talia thank
you